Now, I'm guessing no matter who
you're supporting this November,
you will agree this election
is the (bleep) worst.
-But...
-(laughter)
luckily, the second debate,
we all got to meet Ken Bone!
-(cheering, applause)
-Ken Bone!
The be-sweatered, mustachioed,
undecided (bleep) machine
who stole the Internet's heart,
and then made love to it
sweetly.
In honor of this civic-minded
Build-A-Bear,
we played the hashtag game
KenBoneFacts.
For instance,
did you know that if Ken Bone
unfurled his mustache,
it would dwarf the wingspan
of a bald eagle--
that's a true story.
So... uh, we tracked down
the man himself on Skype,
uh, got to chat with Ken Bone--
he is goddamn delightful--
and we got him to choose
his favorite fact.
Just for you,
ladies and gentlemen, Ken Bone!
(cheering)
Thanks, Chris.
It was a real thrill
to see KenBoneFacts trending
on Twitter on Monday night.
I loved every one of them,
but I can't pick my favorite
'cause I'm undecided.
So I'm gonna read
a few of the best ones.
"He can't attend
an ugly sweater party,
because they all look
so good on him."
-Duh.
-(laughter)
"The Illuminati comes to him
for advice on what to do."
Yep, I actually got
a conference call
with Jay Z and Beyoncé
after this.
(laughter)
"He is the fifth Golden Girl."
Oh, look, and here's
one of the original cast photos.
(applause, whooping)
"Clowns tweet
about Ken Bone sightings."
-(laughter, applause)
-Also true.
But if I ever see one of them,
I'm gonna go Liam Neeson
on their ass.
(laughter)
"Ken's hugs create such
dangerous levels of euphoria,
they had to be regulated
by the FDA."
You know, that's actually true.
You should not operate
heavy machinery
after you snuggle with me.
(laughter)
Thanks so much, Chris.
And I just want
to encourage everybody
to get out there
and register to vote,
because in 2016--
Yes we Ken!
-HARDWICK: Ah, fantastic!
-(cheering, applause)
Ken (bleep) Bone!
Oh, by the way... before
we get off the Bone train,
someone on Twitter sent me this,
the sexy Ken Bone outfit
for Halloween.
So naturally, I had to ask Ken
what he thought about it.
You know, Chris, I did see
the sexy Ken Bone costume,
and while I was
strangely aroused,
I want to point out
that there's only one
real sexy Ken Bone outfit
out there.
-I'm wearing it.
-Yes!
Sexy Ken Bone!
The real sexy Ken Bone.
Get out there and vote,
everyone.